new now at six the snow is melting away
in Kyle Canyon those living there say
they're finding more pets abandoned
right nearby an already stressed animal
shelter system forcing the finders to
either take them in themselves or leave
them abandoned eight news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us The Dilemma
we found two down here just you know in
the last year Jimmy Alderson says since
moving to the mountains eight years ago
his communities found this dog and this
dog and this dog abandoned 12 altogether
in the past year and a half some of them
have been dropped off and they're very
matted they haven't even been taken care
of we do get snakes and snakes can bite
to Jennifer Humphries with the U.S
forest Service it means the dogs become
the prey we don't know what type of
bacteria will be in their mouth and what
kind of disease that could spread to
again both you or your animal your pets
but to professionals like her it leaves
these dogs with a slim survival rate but
if hikers come encounter with one out in
nature it may cause them more headaches
to get them the care they need than
simply just leaving them be
on the animal foundation's website
getting an intake appointment is on a
one month backlog in a statement a
representative tells 8 news now that
while there are exceptions the
appointment system is necessary to
maintain a proper population they can
care for last year the organization
halted all intakes for a month due to a
canine virus outbreak we continue to be
in crisis it leaves rescues like Nevada
SPCA scraping to compensate but
executive director Lori heeren says even
they are at capacity there's only so
many dog enclosures there's only so many
Foster families that we can put them in
we really need to depend on the
community to assist us and to retaining
their pets maybe people got them during
the pandemic and they don't want them
anymore maybe the shelters are full and
they think maybe that this is a good
place for them but it's not